il nous incombe à
tous
de nous acquitter de cette responsabilité. Je tiens à lui
exprimer mes remerciements pour ce
service des plus importants qu'il a rendus à notre
pays le général qui l'
accompagnait il était le commandant à Berlin
pendant l'air laissé dans le  fin quarantaine
mr.  Berlin du
secrétaire d'État du département d'État que m.  Rusk et moi
-même sommes très satisfaits de leur visite et nous
sommes conscients et le vice-président l'a
souligné que nous allons
traverser des semaines et des mois difficiles
dans les temps à venir pour maintenir la
liberté de Berlin-Ouest, mais maintenant
que les échanges ont été utiles  et
fructueux et je pense que ce sera productif,
personne ne peut voir ce que nous avons vu
sans ressentir profondément la grande
responsabilité que l'Amérique a envers le
peuple est pire Berlin-Ouest et envers l'
humanité, ils se tournent vers nous pour des
encouragements, de l'espoir et du
leadership et ensemble nous sommes  va
continuer à marcher épaule l'épaule
jusqu'au bout la
liberté est préservée dans le monde